j'étais explorer l'australie pendant six
mois et ça reste un de mes meilleurs
souvenirs parce que c'était la liberté
absolue c'était la dernière étape de mes
études j'ai entrepris à bruxelles dans
le cadre de ses études on avait la
possibilité de faire un stage comme
c'étaient des études de commerce
international de faire un stage à
l'étranger
et moi je me suis dit je vais essayer de
faire un truc en australie je rêvais en
australie et puis j'ai trouvé un stage
là-bas à sydney et puis ça avéré que
c'était pas vie à des copains de parents
qui avaient des copains à sydney il ya
un monsieur qui m'a gentiment accueilli
chez lui mais en fait il n'est pas
besoin de moi et donc mais rapidement je
me suis retrouvé à dans son entreprise
de galvanisation je pense y avait un qui
m'intéresse moi avec la galvanisation et
et piwi m'ont planté dans un bureau avec
un ordinateur
je suis les ordinateurs elle et moi pas
la peine qua non que j'attendais et puis
je me suis dit bon ben ce que je vais
faire je vais lui proposer de faire une
étude qualitative de
sa clientèle je vais attendre quinze
jours j'ai répond je lui fais un petit
rapport
et puis je me suis barré et puis j'étais
explorer l'australie pendant six mois et
ça reste un de mes meilleurs souvenirs
parce que c'était la liberté absolue
je verrai un petit sac à dos d'école et
j'arrive et je repartais j'avais de
compte à rendre à personne personne ne
savait où j'étais personnes où je
pouvais rester un linge ou à certains
endroits j'ai ma vie là je reste et je
n'aime pas je partais après une semaine
de quelle façon vous dirais que voilà ce
voyage vous a changé mais en fait quand
vous êtes tout seul vous apprenez à vous
apprenez sur vous en faites vous
apprenez à vous situer dans man dans
l'autre en fait dans les relations
passées quand vous êtes dans votre bain
votre votre environnement
mais non voyons ce sens sans rien dire
en l'on donne beaucoup d'informations
quoi tout est sujet à pouvoir situer des
gens à les mettre dans une case quand
vous êtes de l'autre côté du monde en
australie
ce qu'on sait lui c'est qu'il est belge
qu'on m'appelait le belge donc c'est
assez enrichissant de voilà on apprend à
voir les six si on a des facilités
rentrer en contact avec les gens puis
voilà on développe des amitiés des
c'est bien de partir d'une feuille
blanche à un moment dans sa vie pour se
rendre compte qu'ils en aient quoi faire
entrer dans une boîte de production qui
faisait la caméra cachée par part à la
mi mai 10 lun 10 de choisir si ce
travail dans une boîte de
télécommunications une boîte de
production qui veulent également à
cacher dans la boîte de production tu
veux faire entrer la gratteuse je viens
et puis me rappelle le mardi au niveau -
je suis engagé givet et enki deux jours
après j'avais rendez vous avec le patron
et ils m'ont engagé mais vraiment j'ai
les autorisations de diffusion sous les
caméras cachées puis j'ai fait de la
production et assistant de production et
puis j'ai
j'ai continué depuis un moment sur un
tournage la paire antiquités en train de
piéger les gens s'en sortait plus mon
problème à proposer c'est moi je lui
parlais dans l'oreillette il vivait bien
le faire toi alors puis j'ai été puis
c'est un marché et et puis on m'a donné
c'était une des missions et b 5e a gâché
mon nez une puis une deuxième puis une
troisième ou une quatrième puis un
cinquième
et pour finir je faisais toutes les
missions du seul personnage à françois
roux et en fait j'ai pas vraiment
construit que c'est c'est une somme de
deux personnalités que je prends un peu
expliquera plus si tout le monde puis
depuis des attitudes de gens puis des
c'est un peu c'est inconscient en fait
cependant l'événement a commencé un peu
tout ce qui m'énerve
enfin tout ce qui au tout ce qui me fait
rire aussi mais oui çà mau mais mais
mais je compte en faire non on a
beaucoup bossé on va essayer de
retrouver de nouvelles idées puis elle
était faire les repérages autorisation
diffusion et juste avant de commencer à
tourner et ben on a dû se suit ce que
nous savons et est donc ben oui la
manche compte les fermer
mais je compte les faire un moment où on
portera plus le masque parce que c'est
un quinté à ce qui est intéressant c'est
l'expression sur le visage des gens donc
donc j'attends que qu'on solutionne le
problème puis et puis je puisse
recommencer en faire
[Musique]
depuis toujours je vais voir les départs
de deux courses transocéaniques ou le
tour du monde et ça a fini par savoir un
jour franck valle le patron de la boîte
initiative m'a appelé il avait affrété
un bateau qui s'appelle mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque et donc il m'a
proposé de faire la transat jacques
vabre avec avec tanguy de lamotte et moi
c'était un rêve jamais j'aurais imaginé
qu'un jour on a même proposé ça et
sincèrement j'ai pris très cher étant
lui aussi nous pendant cinq jours ça a
été un terreau d'une machine à laver
quoi avec deon sortent avec des lunettes
de ski ont tombé on on était trempé on
dormait un quart d'heure on mangeait pas
buvez un peu d'eau moi j'ai vraiment
pris énormément de plaisir c'est aussi
vous avez un centime en liberté puis une
sortie de man 2 se dire quand vous voyez
la vitesse à laquelle on fait des
pointes à 50 km/h quand vous voyez la
vitesse à laquelle devrait ce bateau et
vous allez bien vous naviguez 24 heures
sur 24 et que vous aviez seulement allé
au brésil
seulement c'est déjà loin mais pendant
22 jours
mais ces immenses en fait de cette terre
quoi alors que quand on est revenu en
avion on a mis 11 heures quoi et en fait
on se dit c'est le chemin qui est
intéressant au kosovo terre quoi c'est
le fêter et c'est pour ça que je
trouvais asus je trouve ça pas mal de
recommencer à voyager localement aussi
prendre le temps d'aller en voiture
d'éprouver les choses parce que parfois
on va trop vite en vêtements fait
partout et quelque part là nulle part
aussi au même moment c'est bien de faire
les choses de se rendre compte de deux
éprouvé